foreign
it's that time of the year again where
we look ahead to the Future and eagerly
anticipate the newest releases in the
world of anime So today we're counting
down the top 10 action anime still to
come out in
2023-24 from pulse pounding fight scenes
to intense battles these shows will keep
you on the edge of your seat and leave
you craving more so sit back relax and
get ready to add some amazing new anime
titles to your watch list but before
that let's take a short break to thank
today's sponsors AFK Arena AFK Arenas
the perfect RPG for us busy bodies and
it's set to take us on an adventure to
another world with a smashing re-zero
collab it combines cool anime Aesthetics
a game system that rewards planning and
strategy and progression systems and
rewards to keep us all playing this fun
game instead of grinding all you have to
do is set your team's check back from
time to time and see your characters
becoming stronger AFK Arenas ready to
spice things up even further as well the
hit mobile game which boasts over 40
million users worldwide is ready to rock
with the biggest anniversary event yet
with 100 free summons and the said
Crossover with re-zero three zero
probably needs no introduction to you
and for AFK Arena's fourth anniversary
the team's letting you get the chance to
see both RAM and Amelia in action
everyone even new players can try the
duo out for three days before getting
more chances of obtaining them for free
don't forget to download AFK Arena
through the link in the description a
hundred summons and fan favorites from
re-zero awaits you in your new trip
through another world
and speaking of re zero let's start the
list with that
we all knew it was just a matter of time
with a smashing success of its second
season we're due for some more re-zero
it's one of the best and most popular
isakai out there and for plenty of
reasons there's the Dark atmosphere The
Bleak Outlook of the world and on the
bright side a lot of characters to like
and get attached to but one thing I feel
doesn't get much attention is how re
zero expertly weaves multiple genres
into the series you get a little bit of
everything there's the mystery Centric
first half of the first season the
action adventure tone of its second half
and a second season that's mostly about
pushing character relationships and
development well for this third season
expect to see more action than ever
before as we gear up for the fight
against the sin archbishops if you
thought re-zero had pretty cool action
sequences before such as the whale fight
or the climax of season two then I'm
telling you you haven't seen anything
yet I just can't wait for more re-zero
and fans will surely agree with this
foreign
bucket list of the Dead
it seems not so long ago when zombies
were the craze back in the early 2010s
and wow it's been a decade already time
flies but I digress zom100 follows the
story of Akira a 24 year old wage slave
and that's putting it lightly hey those
of us who are on the adult side of the
spectrum face that dilemma too and at
times it becomes too much of a burden
that we just can't wait to be free even
if it takes a catastrophe to do it and
that's just what happens when Akira
finds himself smack dab in the middle of
a zombie apocalypse instead of fear it
only reinvigorates him and he goes on an
adventure trying to check off tasks in
his 100 item bucket list his days might
be limited but he sure never felt more
alive than before combining comedy
moments that readers could find
relatable and a healthy dash of gory
light-hearted fun and fan service Zone
100 is said to end up being a scrappy
favorite in the star-studded summer 2023
season
foreign
ER of Misfortune a curse causes her to
bring the worst luck to people around
her so much so that she wants to end
herself that is until she encounters
someone who doesn't seem to be affected
by her curse as much after all when
you're an immortal guy trying to pass on
like Andy there's got to be some awful
amount of resilience in there thus fate
brings the two death Seekers together
and it sends them off on an adventure
where Foucault tries to give Andy the
send-off that he's always wanted along
the way they'll have to Brave perils
which include a mysterious organization
that's taken an interest in their powers
really creative and unique in its
premise I find Undead unlock a really
promising Contender it's an action show
that has a lot of thought put into it
with fight sequences hearkening back to
the likes of Hunter Hunter I wonder how
it's anime will fare but I'll say that
if you're looking for something fresh to
see this is going to be one of my top
recommendations and the best news you
won't have to wait any longer as it's
set to be released this 2023
[Music]
Kaiju number eight is also set to hit
the screens very soon
with the Advent of Chainsaw man it's
fitting that we'll be getting the anime
adaptation of this after all people have
been calling Kaiju number eight the
spiritual successor of the former and
it's not hard to see why you know see
the story is set in a Kaiju ravaged
Japan where Kafka longs to one day join
the special forces in combating these
monsters unfortunately though he doesn't
seem too cut out for it until one day
when a parasitic Kaiju enters him and
turns him into a humanoid Kaiju now in a
new form he's ready to take the fight to
the monsters alongside promising recruit
ishigaba there's just one problem though
in this new form gothgar may have
likewise turned the defense corpse
against him with witty characters high
tension action and a lot of similarities
to big hits chainsaw man and Attack on
Titan gaiju number eight looks to be in
Prime position to be a fan favorite with
the always excellent production IG
taking the helm gaiju number eight could
be the big hit of a new anime that 2024
is looking for
foreign
[Music]
and just when you think remakes are
slowly falling out of favor we got hit
by a bombshell we're only Kenshin is
coming back
says
[Music]
a classic favorite from my childhood
days Roni Kenshin is set to take the
anime World by storm once again maybe
not as much with all these big hitters
taking in a lot of the hype but seeing
who Roni Kenshin returned with
modernized visuals and production
quality made a lot of 90s kids happy
Rurouni Kenshin tells the story of the
titular Kenshin a Wandering swordsman
looking to move on from his past as a
cold-hearted killer varying to never
kill again he aims to turn over a new
Leaf however forces of chaos continue to
move in the shadows and those along with
the ghosts of the past are set to bring
Kenshin back to his path of battle will
he be able to keep his vow and protect
those he holds dear well finally the
current generation of anime fans can
have a chance to experience this story
of romance drama and Redemption Rurouni
Kenshin has been regarded by many as one
of the best the anime had to offer back
in the 90s and I do hope that this new
version will successfully recapture that
magic system
let's resume things with a bang thanks
to bleach
it's generally agreed upon the
bleacher's return last year has been a
resounding success I mean it gave me a
site that I didn't expect to see and I
truly found myself amazed at how it
rejuvenated the fan base that seemed to
have jumped ship for like a decade or so
that's all thanks to the serious and
consistent tone of the series the whole
things get real Vibe and the amazingly
crafted fight sequences several which
had additions to help flesh things out
bleach a thousand year blood War is one
of the few titles wherein I can
confidently say that the anime is the
definitive version of the media and it
left us with one insane Cliffhanger in
Revelation all in time to get us hyped
for the continuation coming this year
things are only about to heat up with
the intensity of the battles ramping up
and the much awaited reveals of powers
coming given the pacing it's been having
we can also see a lot of anime original
content to help supplement the stuff
being adapted to if you enjoyed watching
the first part of thousand year blood
War then the next one is definitely a
must watch
foreign
solo leveling is here to kick things up
a notch further
with a lot of the famous Korean webtoons
getting their adaptations within the
last three years or so one title remains
conspicuously excluded from the list and
that is solo leveling one of the more
popular Korean series yet to have its
anime well that changes soon the solo
leveling has been confirmed to be
getting an anime now if you haven't kept
up with the source material you can
easily get what the buzz is all about
and I'm sure that even if it ended up
being rushed like God of high school we
still have a lot of moments to talk
about once everything's said and done
it's not hard to see why it's very
popular people have always loved these
struggle for survival types of stories
and add to it the whole training in
order to be super overpowered aspect and
we've got the same formula that made a
series like Ali fioretta hit with the
anime loving audience in terms of
presentation the whole dark atmosphere
only adds to the Mass Appeal of the
title and I wouldn't be surprised that
this ends up being everyone's favorite
Korean anime adaptation in the long run
me well I'm more than excited to hear
hiroyuki samano's Banger tunes on this
show once again we'll see how this one
goes
decors continue their momentum this year
with possibly the biggest one yet
muschoku tensei season two
I've come to expect a lot out of mashoku
tensei I mean where else could you see a
light novel that had a literal Studio
created just to adapt it and if they
stick to their words we may very well
see the whole of mushoku tensei adapted
with the meticulousness and Excellence
that they did with the first season the
first season of mushoku tensei was a
great watch an exciting story of
Adventure and growth but we're only just
getting started with him what I'm most
excited about for season 2 is to finally
see more growth out of our protagonist
rudius to see him grow out of his
insecurities as we conclude the arcs
that feature him in his youth fans have
been raving Non-Stop about the big
moments in season two and the excitement
is nothing short of infectious mushoku
tensei fans we're all feasting today
aren't we here's to an excellent season
two and an even better continuation once
it's done
anyone heard of Pluto well let me
introduce it to you
it certainly is an anime to look out for
if you talk in my circles Pluto is a
creation of the legendary anime Creator
Nagi urasawa similar to Astro Boy Pluto
deals with the relationship between
humanity and robots however things take
a darker turn in Pluto as the Swiss
robot Mont Blanc gets murdered at the
start it's empty detective guessig to
investigate this tragedy and in his
Pursuit for the truth he runs into an
entity known as Pluto seeing that the
other robots are in danger races Against
Time in order to save them all running a
fan of both man and machine along the
way it's been a while since we've had
sci-fi Thrillers like this the theme of
the show is nothing new as the whole
coexistence of man and technology has
been done by a lot of anime at this
point in time we had the popular ones
like ghosts in the shell and some less
popular ones like beatless you remember
that one however what Pluto offers is a
unique perspective as its backdrop set
in a world where robots had already
integrated into human society yet the
Specter of hatred continues to loom over
those who are considered sub-human and
what you have here is another addition
to the brilliant resume the Ura Sava had
accumulated in his career
foreign
things up is Jiu Jitsu Kaizen season 2.
it's a bit of stuff daddy it didn't take
so long for jiu jitsu Kaizen to firmly
establish its footing in the anime
sphere now did it I had high hopes for
it before it aired but never did I
expect it to become as big as some of
the Blockbuster titles and Shonen an
anime sure it's not quite post episode
19 Demon Slayer but it feels like it's
just a level beneath that you want some
news though we're only getting to the
good part of it if you like the fights
and the spectacular level of execution
season one Jiu Jitsu Kaizen had in its
key moments get ready for an even more
hyped Arc coming up one of my favorites
in Jiu Jitsu guys and so far will get
its much awaited adaptation and it will
be an arc where the stakes get raised
even higher than before we'll see a lot
of cool moments and a lot of heartbreaks
and I can't wait to see everything in
glorious anime form if you thought
things were a tad bit too easy in season
one well season two puts our characters
against enemies that may be far more
than they can handle I just can't wait
for jiu jitsu Kaizen season 2 and nor
can the fans
foreign
[Music]
that's going to do it for this one for
me these are the top 10 most anticipated
anime that have yet to come out in 2023
and 2024. if you've got some other ideas
on what you think should be included
then comment down below let me know what
you think about that and don't forget to
check out AFK Arena links in the
description I'll see you next time and
thank you very much for watching